son reactores en dos medios de
Pittsburgh el Pittsburgh Just chronicle
y el Pittsburg Union progress pero
decidieron unir fuerzas para cubrir el
juicio del hombre que mató a 11 personas
en una sinagoga local en 2018
estábamos hechos para cubrir esta
historia juntos porque residíamos allí
mismo literalmente en la comunidad que
ha estado cubriéndolo durante todo este
tiempo además nuestra gente en terreno
cubrió incluso antes de que se
identificara el tirador
es un servicio público cubrir esta
historia no es como el caso scoopy donde
alguien va a obtener una mejor historia
de todos modos
trabajar juntos requirió algunos ajustes
como decidir si usar o no el nombre del
tirador
Cuanto más se difunde su nombre más se
le da fama Y glorificación eso es
definitivamente Algo que queremos evitar
siempre utilizaríamos el nombre porque
eso también es Pero somos conscientes de
que no es necesario utilizarlo 30 veces
en un mismo reportaje
cada día un reportero de una u otra
redacción acudía al tribunal para
informar sobre los procedimientos y sus
artículos eran publicados por ambos
medios
formó parte del equipo que cubrió el
juicio
personalmente ha sido extremadamente
beneficioso trabajar juntos y contar con
otro grupo de periodistas talentosos que
se preocupan por la historia que se
preocupan Por hacerlo bien que tienen
ideas similares en cuanto a lo que
significa hacerlo bien lo que significa
hacer lo correcto por la gente
el juicio entrará ahora en una nueva
fase en la que los mismos miembros del
Jurado decidirán la condena del
Pistolero cadena perpetua o pena de
muerte